alors j'ai écouté avec attention
l'audition de du secrétaire général et
il avait parlé d'une condition
sinequanone il a utilisé vraiment ce
terme conditions sine qua non pour moi
une condition sinequanone doit avoir une
traduction au niveau du contrat
il n'y a pas dans dans les conventions
qu'on a signé il n'y a pas de conditions
liée à notre ligne éditoriale dans sa
globalité c'est pas uniquement sur les
questions qui nous intéressent
aujourd'hui mais nous
dans les deux conventions que ce soit la
première ou celle du fond Marianne qui
sont à peu près les mêmes c'est des
conventions type
la plupart des des articles sont liés
plutôt au bon suivi
administratif et et on a pas eu de
d'objectifs on va dire métrique précis
et on n'a pas eu de de
limitation en tout cas écrite sur sur
ces questions mais au-delà au-delà de la
convention dont on peut comprendre que
c'est difficile à écrire de toute façon
mais est-ce qu'il y a eu quand même un
élément dans votre conversation qui
était une recommandation on va dire
alors dans notre conversation
je pense que ça ce qu'il a ce que j'ai
compris en tout cas
c'est parce que dans notre association
beaucoup de membres ont un passé ont un
passé militant ils sont soit dans des
parties voilà quand ils ont des
convictions ils ont des convictions ils
ont des positions qui sont tranchées et
je pense que que ça crainte c'était que
ça déteigne sur sur le projet alors nous
on a toujours été sur
voilà les gens ont des convictions oui
on va y venir mais simplement
factuellement est-ce qu'il vous en a
parlé ou non est-ce que ça fait l'objet
d'un échange alors vous me dites pas
écrit il y a pas d'écrit mais un échange
de confiance on va dire discussion libre
en vous disant faites attention sur le
truc oui non il nous a jamais interdit
de faire des contenus politiques